[Music]
courtney is in indianapolis hi courtney
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks so much thank you how
can we help
yeah my husband is transitioning to a
new job next month it's in a new field
and um i just would like some help
trying to figure out how to set up our
monthly budget and
some of the specifics about 401k and um
yeah the just getting our we have to
start allocating our benefits pretty
soon and i
i'm not entirely sure like how to set up
our new budget because i don't know
exactly what the take-home pay is going
to be
the catch is that he's gonna he's making
a little bit less money with this new
job why
um well he wanted to
i mean in the simplest of terms he
didn't really have a future at his
current company due to the mandate so he
kind of saw the writing on the wall and
so he decided to get out while the kid
was good okay so he had to kind of
switch fields
um the good news is his new new job is
100 remote
and it's based out of texas so we feel
like we have a little bit of security
there
has upside
the yeah the upside is that it's it's
remote so and the upside is he's not
going to get fired for vaccines but but
but i mean is there a career ladder
upside
yeah so i mean definitely very he's kind
of start at the bottom again um but the
trajectory it looks really good and you
know the current job i mean he wasn't
allowed to go into the corporate office
so yeah
there wasn't i mean his future there was
kind of over yeah i understand okay
um the uh
we're getting a lot of people joining
ramsey some really high quality people
joining ramsey for the same reason they
you know they reach the end of their
um time with their other company based
on their
uh policies and so forth so yeah it's
it's a lot of people looking for another
place to work and um all right now the
uh
you're you're out of debt except and you
have your emergency fund
yeah we actually we we moved earlier
this year and we um we bought a new home
and so we have we have a pretty sizable
nest egg now but we're completely out of
debt except for our mortgage okay all
right very good
all right so you'll be putting 15 of
your income into 401k right
so his company will match 36 percent of
six percent
of the 401k so
the problem is it means less money and
so when we bought our home the mortgage
was very very very comfortable um with
his old job and since he's taking a
little bit of a step back what did he
used to make um
about 130. what does he make now
he's going to make a hundred
and
so you're thinking of backing off the
401k at least for a little bit until you
get settled in
yeah okay okay i wouldn't do it
permanently but i might do it for six
months or even a year while you get
settled into the new numbers okay
the old 401k i would get with a smart
vester pro just click smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com find someone in your
area that you like and that we endorse
that does stuff the way we teach and you
know they're ramsey trusted people right
and so um sit down with them and do a
rollover on the old 401 k roll it to an
ira uh do not put it don't if it wasn't
in a roth don't move it to a roth don't
make it taxable but a direct transfer
rollover has no taxes coming out at all
so you want to go ahead and get that set
up you can do that after the first the
year that's fine but i wouldn't leave it
over at the old company
then the second thing is you can start
your 401k you're definitely going to get
that six percent going in you may want
to go ahead and go on up to 10 and then
let's see how we're doing from there as
far as your budget goes
i mean
you're guessing and after one month
you'll adjust it and you'll know so just
give yourself plenty of wiggle room but
you've got a big nest you've got some
money laying around from the sale of
that house right
so if you miss it a thousand dollars you
just pull some money
one time
right
right but i mean we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna do that every month i
don't wanna subsidize your
your screwed up budget out of your nest
egg and then use up your nistic but one
month while you're getting
readjusted to the numbers and getting
them dialed in if you need to pull a
little bit of a thousand bucks pull it i
don't care
i'm pull three i don't care if you got a
bunch of money laying around i don't
know how much you got but that that's
just one thing so you're okay there's no
reason to stress about this and i just
use an 80 figure what's your take-home
pay it's usually 80 it's not gonna be
that far off um
it may end up being a little bit more a
little bit less depending on what he
claims
and um you know in terms of uh the
dependents and so forth he claims on his
w-4
but you know just start working it and
say okay i'm going to set it up based on
this if i come up a little bit short i'm
not going to panic i can either pull
some money or i'll adjust this category
over here after one month you'll have
the numbers
in the second month you'll be able to
just budget on those numbers and that's
what you should do and the good news is
it sounds like you'll be able to so
pretty pretty cool
a lot of folks going through a lot of
turmoil yeah john with um
forced career changes yeah
um by forrest i mean they are um
choosing to
i i want to work in a place that
um
has a different set of values yeah and
uh we're seeing a bunch of
uh i met some folks that joined us last
week here at ramsey and uh the
percentage of them that are ending up
here
because we are in the building
together
they they don't want to be working
remote they've tried it and it didn't
work for them
and
you know the whole vaccine discussion
and all that and people are just
freaking out and
on all sides of the equation but some
people only want to work in a place that
is fully vaccinated right and so it's
cool but it's just what's doing is
causing this tremendous turnover or uh
topsy-turviness turbulence in the
employment marketplace
uh that has nothing to do with your
career right
yeah and that's new
it is new and i
i think it i actually don't think it's
new i think we felt like it's new i
think we were insulated for a season um
but i think
i think it all distills down to
being comfortable with here's my values
and being comfortable with here's the
things i'll put up with and what i want
and then what am i going to do you know
what am i what can i control in this
situation yeah and good news about them
is they went and controlled it they
wouldn't control them
it cost them some money which i i love
that their values were more important
than
x or y and they had put themselves in a
position because they paid off all their
debt that goes back to
that solving for freedom man if you
don't owe anybody any money and then you
get pressed up against the wall with my
values and this is important to me and
my family
man i'm free to shake your hand and
head on down the road yeah and just say
you know bless you yeah i hope that
works for you and i'm gonna
i'm gonna go over here and you know you
don't have to be mean or mad about it
everybody's angry i need to be angry
about everything you just be you and
i'll be me it's okay i gotta change i
thought this was gonna be my future and
now it's not and so i'm gonna and again
i'm making it sound light and easy but
the the least amount of that i can i can
well
it is a lot lighter and a lot easier
to make a change if you have twenty
thousand or forty thousand dollars in
the bank and no debt absolutely then if
you have twenty or forty thousand
dollars in credit card debt and no money
right it's a different it's a different
thing leverage yourself on a house
payment
you can't afford two car payments and a
kid payment my god i mean now your
employer owns you yeah right yeah the
bank owns you yeah yeah there's so i
don't think the borrower's slave to the
lender try this one okay you got no debt
and you walk in the ball starts yelling
and screaming and you start walking off
and you go where are you going i don't
have any payments look over your
shoulder and go i don't have any
payments just keep walking and you know
when you say that that way and you paint
that picture in people's mind they go
yeah this borrower is slave thunder when
i don't have any payments i'll make
different choices i wouldn't put up with
that crap yeah and here's what the boss
is gonna do eight times out of ten
they're gonna want to set up a coffee
with you yeah now uh usually when i get
to work and people run away and you you
just smiled at me tell me what tell me
what's going on here
right that's it that's exactly what you
just looked at over oh as you were
walking out you looked over your
shoulder see you
see you man yeah see you man when you
get down to pretentious i'll be here
dude
temper tantrum somewhere else you
freaking four-year-old
[Laughter]
it's a different thing man what i want a
difference i want people to own their
values
we're in a season now where everybody's
yelling about everybody else's values
yeah how about how about taking care of
you that's not your favorite full-time
job and you know what like me and my
wife we're not going to put it in this
business in the workplace or in the
school great i'm going to own it and
then when you're a kid
yet none your business owner man
there was a
whole sitcom on when i was a little kid
bewitched yeah and the woman that always
looked across the street minded in other
people's business gladys gladys get away
from the window
well here's what they're doing now
the whole stinking culture has gone to
being gladys instead of cairns they're
gladys
this is the ramsey show